hello everybody and welcome to drunk
minecraft with me
markiplier hi I'm Wade yeah weird to my
youtube channel yet I didn't introduce
you yet shut up sorry sorry doctor sir
you're so great mark I love you in every
way
Fox here this is Bob my mom you guys are
dicks
you already ruined a surprise but waits
here - hi guys
I'm Wade God how's it going in the
comments everybody rag on Wade really
hard oh man oh I like the bow Mike shut
up wait I'm sorry I know that Rick he
takes too much [ __ ] your mom takes too
much [ __ ] oh ha ha good get me o
creative mode what are we doing today
well today we're gonna be building a a
creature I don't know what you call it
we're gonna build a statue that
represents all three of us combined
ok so good shop wide alright uh I can't
kill me ha ha ha what am I looking at
here what what what's going on here oh
wait a minute no no boy you guys are
[ __ ] ha ha
I mean wait how do you ha ha ha ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
what whoa stay on while I get down on my
knees high God zombie mode hold still
I'll go zombie I worship everything you
do go go go Oh what happened oh girl
good golly I suppose we should get
started I suppose uh what the [ __ ] what
alright I'm gonna start building you
guys keep doing whatever you're doing
okay I don't write oh they can you guys
just dig around okay all right I'm gonna
do this go goo goo goo goo what are we
doing I'm gonna build a completely wrong
foot over here huh yep MIDI back hey get
him Settlers of Catan oh but dude what
are you building this looks like [ __ ]
I'm gonna blow it up with TNT haha wow
you don't like my building Bob well I
mean a screw you just get away from me
you dick ha ha no Bob come on man
I'm are cells gold disco pants I don't
know why I kind of keep sounding like
Casper ah works awfully quiet not
demanding all the attention hahahaha oh
yeah I I'm trying to figure out what the
hell you guys are doing why building
disco pants oh I guess really good
that's really good no this is wrong this
is all wrong this is wrong no oh come I
Martha you got a breakdown on everything
this is not just fried haar that's not
how it's done what the hell oh wait no
no no no no this is totally wrong no no
brew you [ __ ] I'm gonna go build a
treehouse what the hell
get out mine I'll follow everything you
do mark
I'll follow everything you do here this
is over here you can do the other leg
okay gonna be right all right right
there's a tray wait wait wait it's gonna
be okay right right right right right
okay right here okay okay you want to be
vessels get away from my tree house is a
house it's good
be a penis leg make it a penis leg why
does it have to always be penises mark
what's your obsession with penis is I
don't know I guess I'm gay Oh Scoob
oh no Meatwad we'll meet one yes
me no stupid fat Hobbit does anybody
actually know what's going on anymore
didn't even say what we're building
gasps stupid fat Hobbit is we building
up I don't like spam your impressions
are the only thing I give you credit for
bang bark that means so much this looks
like [ __ ] you going oh my god so do you
Bob what is this I guess it has to be
connected huh it represents us but built
a Coliseum in a church you can't
criticize my buildings cuz I'm
professional minecraft and I love my
girlfriend Molly one one one one one one
Molly one whim well it's ah it's Molly
actually there yes I mean yes Molly's
here
she's right off she's shy oh don't talk
about me oh you oh hello hello just
popped ha ha ha ha I suppose we should
get serious about building now Oh Marc
tell me what you need to do I I got the
penis so that's really all I care about
that's wait is is this still a penis
yeah no that's a penis oh I thought this
was the other leg oh ho ho
why is there TNT over here Bob thank you
dick no Bob don't do it no this
decoration only
hanging off the penis don't do it Bob no
kind of penis looks like the top of a
heart you shut up
it's a little bigger damn dude haven't
you heard of a long penis Bob hahahaha
session with penises makes me sick
Molly likes it right Molly yeah over
when they make the penises shop nurse oh
sorry sorry about my girlfriend
interrupting I hate when she does it and
you should be nicer to Molly
hahahahaha you don't deserve her wait
did I get along great right oh I'm also
fine craft I hate you when you play
games and I are with Mork
I'm sorry
in this event everyone hates mark is
that right is that how it is p.m. you
mark you always ruin everything and hug
the show you never stop talking you guys
like me and not mark but man mark I wish
I had as many subscribers as you oh I
have private conversations with Mark he
wishes he was Wade it's really weird I
don't think that's true at all wait is a
giant [ __ ] I'll admit that I thought
in the third person so oh sorry I got a
little meta there for a second but you
you understand right Molly Oh what god
this this is so horrible
this is the worst idea we've ever done
no you're talking about this like 20
minutes ago we were all this is gonna be
hilarious hahahahaha oh my god
Davin wait wait a minute oh my god is
that really Latin goddess why swine got
us here
oh no oh okay I'm here invincible I
can't keep that up I really can't
good I can't do it it's too much it's
too much oh my god that was horrifying
hahahaha oh look someone built something
for us
Oh mark how's that going hey I found a
lever a lever you guys are [ __ ] shut
up Bob I'm Wade and I'm super more
important than I really am huh it's
about time you realized your importance
ah I don't know what kind of importance
that is but it sounds a little creepy
I'm Wade mmm Oh shadow no oh no wait Bob
say your line oh no you set up my
dynamite ah that's a terrible Bob this
whole idea we're stopping this is
horrible it was a dumb idea
should we stop right now before before
it goes any further
we're done we're done I don't think
we're good enough friends to do that
ha ha ha ha my my Wade was like off the
entire time hey I'm going back to on
disguising myself huh uh-uh am I still
myself now ok I'm back I'm back oh man
ok so that was a horrible idea you want
to keep going yeah I thought we were
gonna keep going oh okay yeah we'll keep
going alright okay alright we'll just
get that zombies oh man in there just
because he's judging us harshly ha ha ha
alright so anyway what we're building
now now that I'm back to being me and
explaining what we're doing we're gonna
build a statue that represents a
combination of all of us so it's gonna
have traits from me Bob and Wade hi Bob
hi Wade
hi Bob hi how's it going can we make it
day can we make it day okay good it's
data all right so what we need to do is
we need to make this a combination of it
and I want this to be a serious
combination so dips out spoke lumps okay
purple gloves and it'll have a red shirt
with an M on it this time so just a
little backwards and Wade what are you
doing
I'm gonna build a giant why is there tnt
in this statue what
there's tnt in this statue Oh for once
it wasn't actually me it was me as Bob
hahahahaha it was me seriously I
couldn't do a Wayde for the life of me
hang on wait talk for a second I'm a we
talk okay I'm talking okay I'm looking
okay I'm talking say your catchphrase
whatever your catchphrase is say it yeah
you have a catchphrase right I doesn't
have a catchphrase uh what's your
catchphrase Bob uh yeah you don't know
cheddar
well I came up with something I said
giggity giggity goo I thought I Matic
that satisfy others I feel like that was
copyrighted No so probably what I was
Dexter wait do that again stupid sister
sweater Cupid you are stupid
and once again you are stupid I think
that's Dexter you're stupid oh I wasn't
really called you stupid I'm sorry no
you're stupid I wasn't calling you
stupid
I see your pants let me see your pants
should we have blue pants for marker or
it's a wage later I'll have black okay
do black no wait what's my pants that
means you two blue two blue do blue
okay oh my god are we actually building
an accurate representation sort of wait
which one of us has pink hair
none of us mmm I'll bob has orange hair
yeah I've worked here that one thing
hang on hang on hang on hang on hang on
I got an idea for this but I'm not gonna
tell you about until it's done so you
keep carrying on to whatever you were
doing and then I'll go and do my own
thing later got it got it everybody got
it Oh got it thanks Bob
Jesus that was the worst bob of them all
I was like you you you're your
impression of Bob which I don't talk
like that all the time you like no you
don't it's very fun it's like that thing
I do Oh what I sound like bad paws like
shaggy who is in a mental hospital is
out of life ha ha ha yeah that was kind
of like what it is you know you know
that's how you are I think everyone can
agree weight in the comment section
everybody vote on who did the best
impression of the other person like who
who had the best voice there I was
dead-on were you were you really I was
really wait what movie did you see the
other day well yesterday me yeah your
man jury really was that still in
theaters
ion's that it isn't that sad I don't
know was it I don't know I remember
watching it I don't know what I thought
of it right out Thackeray it was pretty
good it was good one man know what movie
is good well this is the end and that
movie is freaking hilarious I forgot to
see that movie okay so it's got an M on
it so what do we do about that
uh I've got black wool but I can't make
shapes worth of [ __ ] no I already got
the M in there it's all together okay so
now we should probably put I don't know
glasses on it probably because two of us
wear glasses I do sometimes
what's way it's defining facial
characteristic what the hell is that
what oh god damn it
no damn you don't see anything you don't
see anything at all oh damn it mark
hahahaha you're making it one bigs that
must be my future hahahahaha cuz you're
small get it it's a joke let's ask Molly
yeah Molly chime in here well what is
exactly we're talking about what are we
dealing with here
I want the size of my ego my big size
he's just ashamed
hahahahaha oh really Molly
Willie is our oh yeah yeah seriously out
oh I've got some pictures if you want
them Molly had a penis again surprise ha
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha thank God she
can't hear what we're saying Ashley she
can't my headphones on allow that's not
good
yeah she's heard you guys doing
impressions over all night no I'm not
Molly I'm Laurie yeah yeah yeah is she
sure sure yeah hey that's what happened
shut up you aren't even there I know why
was I supposed to build the pants around
this enormous penis your custom penis oh
I love you Cousteau sleepiness
can we start drunk minecraft quote is it
crooked and that'll be one of them
happening there's three that that's cuz
I know it's a combination
I gave us a yarmulke oh my god is it oh
my god why is this originally just
supposed to be a black patch of hair on
top of it looks like a yarmulke so I'm
sticking my god oh my god this is so
wrong but it feels so right hang on I
got this I got this
wait sorry replace that orange block
that it broke and no no no that's wrong
damn it damn it Wade
what are you doing okay there we go yeah
good I was hoping you would do that
thank you but this one these have to be
white Shh do they this is partly I'm
laid no is it don't just remove them no
white just birch wood planks ha ha ha ha
we're not even birch wood planks birch
wood birch wood logs yeah rich wood logs
ok I'm facing the
scary part facing out yeah that's the ha
ha ha ha ha that's real good replica of
it actually exactly what it was
cuz the eyes are just slightly off and
everything looks just kind of wrong it
looks like oh wait I got a little God
what was it haha for Hokkien or some
Isis odd what the hell
what just I'm looking at this from a
distance you my god flying parts oh my
god it's so is looking at me wherever I
go it's looking at me hey that's what we
look like mark is that is that what we
look like
with that this is a [ __ ] this is
probably the worst thing we've ever
build like if this was actually walking
around this would be scarier than any
monster I don't know that doodle bump
thing we made that one time was pretty
horrifying yeah yeah you're right about
that yeah that was pretty good but I
mean this doodle goose bomb oh you're
giving it a fauxhawk yep oh I like it
right I like it it more like it luck or
is it a black faux hawk on top of our
orange hair it just kind of looks really
stupid so I figure should be accurate
yeah so I don't know this is kind of
creeping me out now I think it needs a
few extra arms just to add that kind of
menacing oh yeah oh that horrible bleep
horribly design Slenderman arms ha ha
hey I've ever given you shut up arms you
shut out they were good don't don't no
it's got my color shirt what marks pants
Bob's gloves and of course mark had to
get the M in there yeah of course why
what's wrong oh you're my TM I've got a
better idea I'm gonna fix it I'm
relieved iam don't worry don't you dare
leaving the M
hahaha now it's an infinity symbol what
the hell
it's a W and M in one but now it looks
like neither so screw you this is awful
this looks like nothing we'll get the
head can he have a penis coming out of
his head
I I mean cuz then he's a [ __ ] ah are
you trimming that one
ah ah shut up you guys you just suck
guys don't appreciate my humor he's
gonna have penises for ears penises for
everything else
yep Mark's making a replica of himself
now Bob we should go make her own a
giant dick head hey hey yeah cuz it's
funny shut up and I fixed it
oh is that the tongue hanging out of
there yep didn't that be pink
sure OOP OOP OOP no hope hope there we
go that looks better
all right is he done oh my god this is
probably most oh my god why is there a
pig snout the penis what why are there
signs Lily Bob really hang out which one
did you sign me to what oh man oh man
good one off to the left there you go
and the ones on the head I shall be mine
compensate just a little bit why
baby for you mark can we do a wolf slab
zombie wool slabs yeah yeah whatever
wool slabs what are those there's
something not released yet a super top
secret you project even know about it's
coming out microp my minecraft 1.73 no
keep talking listen that's all I'm
saying the wrestlers I know it secret
why is there something's on it who's
here with the rest of it also mark haha
that's not a penis so
it's a tongue weight it's a little bit
big three if it was a penis hey screw
you the hair guy was all mark the orange
and black and brown mixture at the penis
in it yeah thank you it's very nice
mm-hmm
wait I don't know you could stack signs
on top of signs I didn't know that Bob
you know you're very silent when you
when when you live oh good thinking this
one is just because it's cool
this one is what Oh God where'd my son
go they fell off they died make it day
it's too much night we need all day I
think you guys should make fan art of
what the three of us combined on here
would look like yeah
no college is like yeah not this this is
copyrighted whatever you guys think like
if we merged into one being what would
we be it would probably look kind of
like this really and yeah like with the
mahogany boat our name be hell if I know
jeez Lord Moy plier Lord way plier what
what is this is that hair coming out of
its ear know what you're talking about
the ear penis no the other side where
it's black oh okay well then I have no
idea what you're talking about my
expertise is really only in penises
yeah well Bob's building this one a
penis hole in a piece this is this real
or what what is this you what are you
just busy doing I'm not looking at it oh
never mind that that's the real one huh
Oh oh my I was Moe's you all along
there's just - markiplier sliding around
oh I still look like markiplier no you
don't but mark and Mark do hey what's
going on over there I don't know what's
going on over here go there's lots of
marks that's all I knew
just as it should be there's a lot of
imitators people like to be oh there's
me I see me that got weird you got weird
good come back
thank you I try hard I know the best he
can do everyone just give him credit
thank you thank you so much
all right his back leg is now officially
done let's see are you gonna deface my
art where where my fair cow don't ask me
it just appeared out of nowhere where
rule one where oh that's you I can't
disguise in anything because people
won't be able to see it none where why'd
you change my e Wade yeah I didn't mess
with you I'm not messed with anything
over here where rules someone changed
all my stuff that I mean what does where
rule mean this it's two words mark oh I
didn't at all I seriously did not get
that what is where where rule I was
wondering I thought you were making a
combination of our names where that's
okay do all right everybody this is what
we've made I'm gonna end this episode
here because it's just evolved on a crap
so anyway Bob as a Twitter Wade as a
YouTube channel both are in the
description so thank you so much for
tolerating with whatever the hell
happened in this episode we don't know
don't ask don't question anything
it was awful we regret everything about
this episode I regret nothing thank you
all so much for watching and as always
wait Bob do you want to the outro
as me oh yeah might as well oh my voice
is so sore from doing that already
thank you everyone for watching uh bob
has a Twitter oh it has a YouTube
channel of Washington's Eleanor scooped
an mama
uh this is fentruck minecraft did I
forgive day a courier up hurry up I'm
way Oh God do pursue a second as always
I will see you in the next episode bye
bye
Bobby
locked
Oh
whoa
after your loan